-You know what I love?
-What?
-I love podcasts.
-Ah!
-Podcasts are a great way
to pass the time
on your way to work,
you're going for a walk,
working out at the gym.
-Sure.
-Whatever you want to do,
wherever.
I listen to podcasts 24/7.
-Yeah, you love them.
You love podcasts.
-I do.
I listen to Birbiglia.
I love that one.
"Working Out" is a good one.
"The New York Times"
has one that's great.
-Yeah.
-I have -- How do you
listen to your podcasts?
Like, what app?
-The Podcast app.
On the Apple, you know.
-Yeah, I have a different app.
-What do you have?
What app do you have?
-It's called like
Casting Shadows or something.
-Really?
-Yeah. Yeah, that's the app.
Anyways, I listen to it
all the time.
And there's so many
podcasts out there,
but there's a lot of
obscure ones
that I had never even
heard of before.
So I thought,
like, maybe we could
check a few of them out tonight.
It is time for
"Tonight Show Podcasts."
Here we go.
♪♪
♪ "Tonight Show
Podcasts" ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Wow! Can you hear?
-What's that?
-Can you hear?
-No, I was doing
noise canceling.
-They're cute.
Are those your
daughter's headphones?
Those are cute.
-No, these are mine.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
These are --
The first podcast is called --
It's called
"Shining Time Statham."
It's a podcast for kids
where actor Jason Statham reads
stories about
Thomas the Tank Engine.
-Oh.
From "Shining Time Station."
-Let's listen to this, yeah.
[ Knuckles crack ]
-Wow!
-That's interesting.
-It's a very specific podcast.
-Yeah,
it's a very specific podcast.
But, again, these are all
fun and obscure.
-These are great.
These are -- There you go.
-And why would he
have to do it, you know?
-I think he probably
did it for fun.
He loves Thomas.
-Yeah, yeah. That's cool.
-He loves
"Shining Time Station."
-This next one --
-Oh, those are beard-phones.
I love them.
-I like it like this
because it's more subtle...
-Right.
-...when I'm on the train.
-Yeah. And then, also,
if you run into something,
you're protected.
-That's correct.
-Yeah.
-Alright, so, this one --
this one sounds pretty simple.
It's just a podcast where
the host explains
the Marvel Universe.
-Oh! What's it called?
-Yeah. Check this one out.
-[ Groans ]
[Bleep] Guys...
-Okay.
-Wow!
-A lot of Earths.
-616?
-Yeah, 616.
This next podcast is called
"A Pilot and a Subway Driver --
a New York City Subway Announcer
Ordering Fast Food."
-The whole podcast is that.
-There's numerous episodes.
I don't know which
one this is, but yeah.
It seems self-explanatory,
but let's take a listen to this.
[ Both shouting indistinctly ]
-Yeah, it's fantastic.
It's good.
-Wow! That's the
second good episode.
-Yeah. That was the best.
You've heard it before.
-Oh, I listen to it
all the time.
I love it.
-Yeah.
This next one is called --
It's a true-crime podcast.
-Ooh!
-I love true-crime podcasts.
This one is called
"Whatever's Left."
And it focuses on crimes
that haven't been covered
on other podcasts yet.
-Oh, wow.
-I think they're running low
on material, I think,
but let's take a listen.
[ Dramatic music playing ]
[ Cellphone dings ]
-You got to act quick.
-Act quick.
-You have to act quick, yeah.
You have to.
-You got to scoop it up.
-Alright, this next podcast
is called "Build--"
It's called "Building --
-Oh, it's wireless. I see.
-What's that?
-Yeah, that's your antenna,
your Bluetooth wire.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, this hooks in --
-There you go.
-If you loop it --
You loop it near
whatever device
you're listening to.
-Oh, I see.
And then it just takes
the stream.
-It streams it.
-Yeah, streams
it through that cord.
-Yeah, like,
if you just flip it,
if you've got a phone there or
whatever, whip it around.
-Like a lasso.
-Yeah.
-Wow! Good signal.
-Whip it around.
Hiya!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
But this one --
this one is called --
This podcast is called --
-Oh, it's an eye one. Oh.
It goes straight to the brain.
That's great.
-It goes through the skull.
-Right. Like a phone bone
or whatever.
-Yeah, it's a phone bone.
Yeah, it vibrates
the skull bone,
and that's how you hear it.
Better on the eardrums.
-Yeah, very helpful for the
eardrums, bad on the brain.
-That's correct.
This podcast is called
"Building Buzzer Blitz."
And this is a game show
where the host goes to
random New York City buildings
and buzzes different apartments
to have them
answer trivia questions.
-Oh.
-Check this thing out.
[ Doorbell buzzes ]
♪♪
[ Click, doorbell buzzes ]
-Ah
[ Doorbell buzzes ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
-Yeah, interesting.
It's very interesting.
-Very interesting.
-Anyway, that's
all the time we have for
"Tonight Show Podcasts,"
everybody.